so we are coming to Westminster because
that's where the power lies and the
government has until 5 p.m on Monday the
24th of April to agree to enter
negotiations about the two Collective
demands that we have presented to them
today
they've had decades to do something time
is up
if we don't get a response at 10 A.M on
Tuesday 25th of April Extinction
Rebellion will build an unprecedented
Coalition stepping up our campaigns in
the weeks and months ahead along three
pathways that is to pick it to stand in
solidarity with the strikers
to organize locally
and to disobey
this is the work we have to do and this
time we won't be alone it is a full day
coming together of over 200 groups with
memberships totaling millions of people
in this country and globally to decide
what is more what more radical action
would look like for them